so this is something I can't wait to try
I'm going to mirror my display into my
headset and edit the video that you're
seeing right now we're going in oh
here's my computer this is showing a
little connect I that's just popped up
so let's look at it we're
connecting and
now oh my freaking timeline is now in
front of my
face this is unbelievable okay the only
problem is okay I don't know where all
my keys
are this is messing with my brain
because it looks so good like look at
this like I'm just moving this all
around my room the other cool thing is
if I wanted I could bring up any other
apps here I can just have my YouTube
channel over here like this is just it's
awesome should I bring a dinosaur in we
were editing and now we're not it's so
close to me dude I'm honestly going to
I'm so scared